not everyone but some you'll see some
reviews some people after seeing some
things in this movie are gonna be like a
lot of voya just sensitive people being
sensitive
[Music]
once upon a time in Hollywood so once
upon the time in Hollywood is the ninth
film by Quentin Tarantino he is going
for ten don't know if it's gonna be a
Star Trek movie Kill Bill Vol three I
hope it's a Star Trek movie I want to
see Michael Madsen wearing a federation
uniform sue me I think that'd be awesome
but I first heard about Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood I heard like it's this
Charles Manson movie it's not it's not
that this movies about two men in
particular an actor named Rick Dalton
and his best friend slash stuntman cliff
Boothe laid by Leonardo DiCaprio and
Brad Pitt and we get some quippy
Tarantino dialogue you're used to at
this point the Quentin Tarantino movie
essentially it's about these guys kind
of in the twilight years of their career
and they're kind of coming to grips with
it ninth film by Quentin Tarantino
I usually don't open with me bagging on
a movie so I'll talk about what I
enjoyed in this movie I enjoyed that
characters I enjoy the theme of a couple
guys just trying to figure out like
where are they going is their usefulness
ending are they are they reaching the
end of their career they're trying to
deal with that I really enjoyed that
I enjoyed the dialogue the shenanigans
the situations they were in I really
liked when they're filming a movie but
you're watching the movie and it looks
like the movie but then you hear the cut
all right what's my line thing but and
then they reset the camera it was an
interesting way to see production to see
the film so in the end when I say I'm a
Quentin Tarantino fan one might say I'm
a fanboy because it kind of gets his
claws in you early on and you enjoy his
style because it's a very unique style
like the genie of the lamp often
imitated never duplicated however when I
walked out this movie I couldn't help
but think to myself I enjoyed it for one
watch I don't need to watch it again
it's kind of a bummer for me to say it's
just not what a Tarantino's strongest
movies it's one of his weaker movies but
even the weaker ones are enjoyable
movies I feel like I'm watching Quentin
Tarantino's private joke with his
colleagues in Hollywood like you're all
like oh you know production meeting so
this is looking like huh you get it
maybe he played it smart but maybe that
was his move I don't know for sure this
is varying conjecture because I heard
that this movie got like a 10-minute
standing ovation from film festival
whatever it was I know I'm imagining
that I'm imagining a bunch of these old
critics directors and producers like
1969 Hollywood I remember you remember I
remember like they'll get it they
connect with it I'm here with my dick in
my hand like oh I'm enjoying it for one
watch I mean you can tell the talent
still there in the writing dialogue
filming execution directing but it's the
driving force in this movies just feels
weak for Hawaii about an hour and a half
into this movie I was like where are we
going other than a couple guys just
trying to be like am I too old for this
[ __ ] I might be too old for this [ __ ]
but like things were happening but
nothing was really happening other than
a film got made in a film in the end I
just I felt like this movie comes across
as a bit indulging like it's tarantino
like oh yeah Hollywood frenzy like that
you get it and I get those movies of
love letters in 1960s Hollywood's that I
always hear that when I have a critique
someone there will be someone who says
it's a love letter and I get that but
that's not gonna carry a film nice guys
was a love letter to old Hollywood I'm
just saying it got into my head I'd
rather watch nice guys and once upon a
time in Hollywood I just didn't feel the
dialogue was as sharp in this movie as
it's been in other Tarantino films I
didn't feel like the characters were as
interesting in this movie as they've
been in other Tarantino films I didn't
feel like the tension was as thick as
it's been in other Tarantino films this
one seen a pretty good tension and I was
pleased with that and then it was gone
man I'm gonna make a comparison I don't
think anyone else has just in the sense
I get directors have to grow and evolve
and you can tell Tarantino is very
seasoned in this movie but does it come
across as interesting in that enter
Lincoln Park yeah I'm a Lincoln Park fan
always have been and chester bennington
rest his soul however undeniably for me
it's the earlier albums of Lincoln Park
that's where my love is and as albums go
on you hear the style change because
people change and so their arts gonna
change I suppose I could have used any
band that evolves their music with them
but I use Lincoln Park and Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood is like one of the
Linkin Park albums I'm like I get it I
still feel the flavor in there but you
know it's not really grabbing me like
your other stuff has just kind of
indulgent and I don't care and one sweet
ass [ __ ] scenes not gonna make me go
oh the whole two-hour 40-minute ordeal
it's all good now no that seems awesome
no prolongs upon the time in Hollywood
it's just gonna be one of those writings
that gets me in the comments section
let's just get it over with yeah it's a
party best I can say it's like this if
you're a big Quentin Tarantino fan if
you're a Quentin Tarantino fan at all
it's worth a watch for sure if you're
not a Quentin Tarantino fan this isn't
gonna convert you like there are some
Tarantino films like if you have a
friend who's like I love revenge movies
not really dig in Tarantino never seen
Kill Bill you it's logical to be like
you should watch Kill Bill just to say
this one if you're not a Quentin
Tarantino fan it's not gonna make you
one all right so once upon a time in
Hollywood have you seen it what you
think about it you probably have not
just thought of that I
that I always ask that question it's a
couple days before it happens but a
couple days from now that question will
be relevant so I'm gonna hold to it have
you seen it what do you think about
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]